[Music]
it's keto time
[Music]
keto keto
keto i challenged you to get my keto
video to 20 000 likes and you surpassed
that goal plenty and i'm actually really
excited about this i'm unfortunately
fresh out of a breakup so i'm more
motivated than ever to change my
lifestyle around be healthier look
better i want to take you guys along for
that journey my one month of keto starts
now
[Music]
[Music]
just
do it
all right i'm gonna have my very first
keto meal it's the middle of the day i
didn't have breakfast so i guess you
could say i'm intermittent fasting today
as well this is my meal here beef chili
with
o aksa cheese oh ok
and cauliflower rice to my surprise the
first few days of keto weren't that bad
i was totally expecting that i would go
with keto flu symptoms right off the bat
it wasn't that bad i didn't have sugar
withdrawal
all right well i'm at the gym right now
it's my first heavy workout while on
keto and i gotta admit i'm incredibly
tired and i got a good night's sleep so
it's not because of that i suspect that
it's probably because i haven't had
carbs in four days
or at least not enough to make me uh
replenish my glycogen stores the weight
stayed the same my strength was there
but i fatigued much earlier in my sets
can't even be certain it's to do to the
keto diet but
that's what was happening
bro you're the worst all right my man
just shot a shot
made me drop my phone
this guy right here wannabe basketball
player all right today's my first day of
cardio
with keto on board and i gotta admit i'm
feeling pretty tired
i just beat both of these guys though i
was able to keep up with them and my
sprints were fine and my game was fine
but i noticed that after a game or two
when i would be somewhat out of breath i
was totally burnt i was really tired
much more than usual again not certain
that it's 100 due to the keto diet but i
do suspect keto is playing a role in my
decreased stamina in my exercise
wait wait the keto struggle is so real
i'm eating cat food let me at least fix
my hair make sure i look good while lisa
is eating a healthy salad hi with some
croutons in there yeah i'm eating cat
food it's not cat food
tell them about the cat food it's salmon
damn cat food we're getting cat food
it's right there that's called the keto
struggle going into the second week of
keto i was starting to struggle a lot
with my food choices when i go to work
and i'm going to be working a long shift
i can't bring all of these goodies and
avocado and all this stuff so what did i
do
i brought a thrive market can of salmon
with some mayonnaise and i basically ate
cat food eating a diet that's so high in
fat i mean 75 of my calories were coming
from fat it's difficult uh to maintain
that and i don't plan well for example
if i'm going to a big event i should
probably eat beforehand i'm at the
sebastian maniscalco
concert the keto struggle is real
because this guy
is eating a full hot dog
and i gotta suffer right now with this
you have to plan ahead if you want to
stick to keto because when you go to a
fast food joint or a restaurant yes they
may have a piece of meat but eating high
protein is not keto you have to be
eating high fat so you have to be
thinking about what it is you're going
to choose off the menu and you can get a
cheeseburger that's very fatty has sauce
on it that hopefully is carb free that's
not optimal keto that's like the dirty
keto that people talk about you're
eating high saturated fats overcooked
red meats using processed oils that's
not something i generally recommend or
want for myself
two weeks in i already had some results
showing my clothes were fitting better
my abs were coming out of hibernation
like one of them legit came out and said
what up and i was like oh my god look
it's my app i used to see you back in
the day and then you started hibernating
it did surprise me that after two weeks
of keto i was already starting to see
results and now i get why this diet is
so popular amongst people who are trying
to lose weight quickly and not that i'm
advocating for that but it was nice to
see results so early on and quite
motivational i will say though the
majority of the weight loss that happens
in the first week or so is usually water
weight that's not gonna be sustainable
that speed of weight
loss i feel like on keto
i wake up really hungry normally i i
don't mind skipping breakfast but on
keto i'm starving it's probably because
i'm eating so much less calories than
usual getting into the later weeks of
keto i was getting hungry that doesn't
mean i wasn't satiated i mean eating a
lot of fats you get full quickly and
you're no longer hungry but when i say
hungry i mean more like cravings bananas
cookies and cream milkshakes and then i
even noticed a pattern where i was
hungry just because i was bored i had a
high fat meal i had some sardines with
guacamole i'm full
and i want to munch on something i just
want to eat some chips so i realized i
like to board eat
and on keto you really can't board eat
unless you just eat nuts all day but how
much i don't understand how many almonds
you can eat in one day before you
i think i broke keto
i mean not technically i had uh
several drinks last night that
technically throws you out of keto
they were not sugary drinks i just had
soda and alcohol but
that does technically take you out of
ketosis at least for a short while so
you probably think i'm a failure
look we all make mistakes and two steps
forward with one step back is still one
step forward that's something that i
want you to remember and take away from
my keto journey if you mess up it's not
the end of the world it doesn't mean
that you're a failure yes i had a few
drinks and it took me out of ketosis for
a little bit because your body actually
metabolizes the alcohol and uses that as
energy instead of fats but it's fine as
soon as i stopped drinking the alcohol
the next day i was probably back in
ketosis and everything was back on track
so did it slow down my progress probably
somewhat but it wasn't the end of the
world if i treated it like it was the
end of the world that would hurt my
progress because that would demotivate
me and cause me to order some cookies
and cream milkshakes and we know we
can't do that on keto i had a renewed
determination to continue and finish my
keto journey
even at the mall
one month of keto's in the books i made
it i ate 75
of my calories from fat 20 from protein
5 from carbs i stuck to this bad boy but
let's talk summary let's talk about what
happened first and foremost body i
started this diet at 208 pounds i ended
i weighed in this morning at 202 pounds
so that's a six pound weight loss in
four weeks
sounds pretty appropriate about a pound
and a half per week my abs are showing a
little bit more which gets me really
excited for summer now when it comes to
my mind i don't necessarily feel
any big difference that jumps out but i
do notice that i don't crash as much
especially in the midday section let's
talk recommendation
[Music]
for the average healthy person going on
a short
course of keto will help them lose some
weight and it probably won't be
detrimental to their health if you're
going to start a new diet any diet for
that matter go see your doctor and have
that conversation figure out what are
the benefits versus harms so you can
make the most educated decision possible
moving forward i hope you guys enjoyed
me trying out keto if you want me to
continue trying out weird things diets
whatever drop it down below in the
comments and smash that like button and
if you tried keto and you had an
experience of your own also jump into
the comment section as you know i'm very
active down there get your mind out of
it
and if you want to see more about my
take on diets click here for my playlist
and as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]
you